greetings from podcastville the joint
is brought to you by stamps.com
listen this holiday season since you
can't go see grandma in person
you're going to be mailing a lot of [__]
instead the post office isn't just going
to be busy it's going to set new records
you don't need the hassle with
stamps.com you can mail anything
from the convenience of your own home
plus it saves you deep
discounts you can't get at the post
office
stamps.com is tremendous how long have i
been doing a podcast
how long have i been selling stuff my
wife has been on stamps.com
you pack it up you put it by your
mailbox
the mailman picks it up no drama no
nothing
your house becomes the mail the mail the
post office whatever the [__]
anyway do me a favor stamps.com
brings the post office into the comfort
of your home
don't spend the middle of your holiday
season at the post office this year
sign up for stamps.com instead it's easy
it's simple there's no risk and with my
code joey
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments
or contracts it's easy go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
home page and pressing joey
that's it that's stamps.com
preston joey and never ever ever
go to a post office again that's it the
church is also brought to you by
family cbd lion pride and performance
from the gummy bears to the cbd infused
kidney acid
tape to the the back balls to the
tincture
listen i live on cbd line i'm an old man
i got pains and rattles i put a piece of
tape on before i go to the gym on my
knees and my shoulders
and i'm tip top [__] magoo
who else does this in the cbd world
information everybody tells you they're
selling cbd
but nobody gives you the information go
to cbdline.com right now
and look at the third-party lab results
for yourself
we're not messing around so do me a
favor go to cbd line and press in
joey and get 20 percent off delivered
right to your [__] house
every week the percentages change i
don't even know what they are no more
they just take good [__] care of you
when you press in
joey go to cbdlion.com
and go to stamps.com to get the party
started
now it's time for uncle joey's joint
[__]
candles lit
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 28th
of october the month is almost [__]
gone we did it
we made it nobody's [__] dying
the numbers are up but people are living
who gives a [__]
uncle joey's joint is here and in color
i hope you guys are watching the comedy
store documentary i hope you're watching
some type of uh
i hope you got show time where you got
an app or whatever the [__] you got
because uh you're missing some great
stuff i i think mike binder
did a great job the last four episodes
i've been getting a lot of
positive feedback and it's not that he
put me in anything
it would have still been interesting
even not to see myself on there but
i don't know if you were watching it
there was one picture they showed
uh after the joe rogan telling the story
about uh
you know getting banned and whatever
they said that it really slowed down and
jimmy schubert
goes you know diaz left joe left
and they show uh an suv a cadillac
pull up and it's me and rogan and the
cadillac and i have my red
north bergen [__] uh jacket on which
was given to me
by the great legendary coach vinnie
askley's up in north bergen
i tell you i got more calls from wearing
that [__] jacket
on that documentary that i've gotten
from doing anything like my friends all
called me and said we're so [__]
proud
that you represented north bergen north
bergen was represented
saturday night at the ufc my man kevin
hawks whatever i don't know him i didn't
even know he was from north bergen
i didn't even know he was fighting i
didn't even even know there was a
[__] mma gym
in north bergen i know anaconda jiu
jitsu is up there julio rodriguez's
school but i didn't know anything else
is up there
so now i have to start looking when i go
back up there i don't go up there that
much
but a bunch of buddies of mine called me
and they were like hey man
thank you for repping north bergen and
we didn't know that rogan
and you had that much hair i was like
you guys didn't know rogan had hair like
they're like we didn't know he had that
much hair what happened but we got old
times [__] move on this is what
happened that's how long
i've known him i did the math that was
new year's 2001 fear factor was in full
effect
every year from like 2000 to 2006
we did even later than that we did new
year's every [__] year
uh but that got to the point we we would
just do the improv
and on melrose we would do the eight
o'clock
the ten o'clock bring in the [__] new
year
at the mill rose improv and then we
shoot over to the [__] comedy store
and we close out the [__] night there
have a great time
you know this is what it was it i think
the last big new year's show we did
was with honey honey and doug stanhope
and uh
duncan and ari we did one at the wilton
theater
that was it but every year that was our
thing
with me ari duncan joe
redband we do [__] new years
and then we'd take it over to the
[__] store and go bananas up there
holtzman would be up
who thank god they gave light in this
documentary
brian holtzman you know over the years
there have been a lot of [__] things
and i'll break them down for you right
now
i think one of the funniest stand-ups
working
is bill burr i think joe's up there too
i think dave chappelle is up there i
think there's a lot of great comics
working
but nobody i think i think bill burr
really has it
to the full extent as far as a
wild man on stage i mean
i have those qualities and i'm a
storyteller and whatnot
but there's another guy that
just listen man in in anything
in any any [__] aspect of life
whether it's roofing
baseball sports ufc you know
i saw it i first started learning about
it when
i worked for a sports betting service
you know
most sports betting service if you
belong to one what they do is if they
have a hundred clients
let's say pittsburgh is playing the
dallas cowboys
what they usually do is they give out 50
people pittsburgh
and 50 people are dallas cowboys i
worked for a sports betting service that
did not do that
they gave everybody the same picks but
what uh they would do is you know they
would cater it
to your whatever you wanted to play
let's say you were
you're a parley guy you want to bet two
teams and go for bigger money a
five-time parlay is thirty dollars to
lose
seventy dollars to win that's what it
was when i was gambling when i was back
a kid
ten time paul is sixty dollars to lose
140 to win
sometimes you have paul a people who
want to make two picks
there was this guy that i had that was a
the nicest guy in the world
and every night we go three and one
three and one three and one and i always
gave him
the one i don't know what it was every
night this guy was like a [__] coach
somewhere in missouri i really liked him
i didn't want to have what everybody
else had
but i was giving him the wrong judgment
we would give out four games a night you
know
a college basketball game maybe three
nba games something like that
you know on an average but i would
always give you know you would have like
a chart and it would have the four teams
and who you were giving those teams to
if you go back at those charts i always
gave him
the one that lost he was a hell of a
nice guy
he left me as a client i would have left
me too i was giving him nothing but
losers
but uh he just fell through the cracks
we were winning
we were actually [__] winning i think
the last year i worked there i had a guy
that was paying me out the ass we were
winning we were doing really well we
went on a hot streak
when you go on a hot streak everybody
hears about them gambling and they jump
on the bandwagon with you
but this poor guy this poor coach listen
he doesn't even matter it's been
[__] uh you know 25 years since i
worked on the sports betting service
that guy has moved on i've moved on but
i still think about that guy i applied
him to life
that sometimes people just fall through
the cracks there's nothing you could do
to control it
and brian holtzman who they put on that
portrait on this uh spec on the
documentary this week
bro that guy made us laugh for [__]
years
that guy brian holtzman is one of the
true
funniest [__] working he just
didn't have the
[__] you know he's a nut like me he
didn't have the [__] time to play the
game or the patience to play the game
sweetheart of a guy kill her up on stage
my favorite brian holtzman story is we
put a fart machine
in the [__] room while he was on
stage one night
and the kid who had the fart machine
kept putting it off and brian holcham
was trying to do his jokes this is from
the con
you know if you're watching a
documentary they're telling you [__]
that you know you guys
you cannot believe i mean i was at the
comedy store in 97
when there was eight people on a [__]
wednesday night
you know you think about all the gold
and glitter
and all the [__] that was going on down
in the last seven years
dog before that it was a rough [__]
place
i know tons of comics i could mention
names that walked in there
looked at me and said i don't know how
the [__] you do this and walk the [__]
out of that
it was tough it was tough to only a
certain type of comic went down there
not a lot of comics went down there
and the comments that did go down there
were rough and tumble type guys
that was a rough [__] place but brian
holtzman at night would make that
[__] place so much better because
after all the bumps
after everybody got bumped after
everybody left mad
brian holtzman was a trooper in fact it
was brian holtzman who told me something
one night somebody bumped us
because they talked a lot about bumping
on the documentary bumping is when
you're about to go up
at 11 o'clock and the star walks in and
goes on stage and now you got to sit
there like a [__] mook the lure
want me to tell you something i never
got mad at that i could look you guys
straight into the face
and tell you i never got mad at bumping
because
i always knew that was part of the game
it's like when christopher multusani
complained to tony soprano
about always having to pick up dinner
because he was a low man on the totem
pole
and he's like what are you worried about
someday some kid's gonna be buying you
dinner it's the same [__] concept
you know when you when you're at the
comedy store and you're [__] green
[__] you're gonna go through a lot of
suffering and a lot of mental [__]
anguish
whether or not you know you're even good
whether you're getting bumped it was
always a surprise
you didn't know if eddie griffin was
gonna bump you dice was gonna bump you
paul mooney was gonna bump you gary
shanley was gonna bump you you didn't
know
it was the night of bumps there were
some nights those stars just came in and
bumped themselves
like there were nights where who went up
last night [__] it eddie griffin went up
dice went up and mooney closed it up
till two in the morning nobody went up
but that was all part of the [__]
game a lot of you guys are there sitting
at me going i wouldn't say that yes you
would
because you had nowhere else to go you
had to sit there pinned
in case this guy got off [__] stage
you know how many nights i sat there and
waited
just and couldn't do coke don't tell me
oh it's because you were doing coke
couldn't do coke i was going up on stage
how the [__] can i do coke i could just
walk around and talk to people
and [__] like that but that's how i
built my friendships with hari and joe
and [__] duncan and red band was just
sitting around waiting you know how many
comics would say [__] you
i'm leaving but it was brian holtzman
who one night back there in 97 i'm like
i can't believe
i'm waiting around for a 145 spot he's
like
you don't want it go put it out go get a
chalkboard and put out
on the street joey doesn't want his 145
spot who wants to do it
see how many people will sign up in that
[__] spot
so brian holtzman set me straight right
[__] then and there i mean brian
holt's been setting me [__] straight
like
listen you just gotta wait that's part
of the [__] game that's part of
becoming a comic and you know what by
waiting
after a while you don't even want to
talk to people no more you just want to
watch that comic and learn
and for me it was lucky because in my
world there was paul mooney who i had to
follow
and tk whatever his name was and don
marrero
and andrew so by following those guys
it made me the comic who i am today
you know joe rogan always says that it
killed me because a lot of people would
give joe [__]
and a lot of people give me [__] i still
get [__] about it people say that's the
funniest man walking around
and people go no he's not a joker bill
burke that's not how joe meant it
joe meant it in the sense of listen let
me tell you something look what just
happened in front of your eyes
comedy central went out of business and
quibby went out of business
you haven't mentioned that i haven't
mentioned that about quibby going out of
business
could be was a jeff katzenberg or
whatever [__] project
where it was 10 minute shows and they
would shoot 10
10 minute shows well those [__]
went out of business and it's like tim
dillon said the other day god bless tim
dylan
because he says it right quibby went out
of business and all of us didn't have a
job
you know comedy central went out of
business because
america finally woke the [__] up how the
[__] were all these comics hiding
and you were promoting all these other
comics you know
they were hiding the ari they were
hiding me they were hiding
tons of people that were exposed in the
joe rogan podcast
so where did comedy where was comedy
central's [__] credibility
i mean i'm not putting comedy central
down listen if it wasn't for comedy
central
with aries your fear this is not
happening i wouldn't be where i
am that show was [__] that show made
me who i am today
it let me showcase my storytelling and i
went deep on there
and i didn't do it for comedy central i
went deep on there for my brother hari
because i wasn't letting him the [__]
down
you know i didn't have a beef with
comedy central but they never thought
about me for anything so [__] them i did
that show
and put my [__] soul on the line
please it's a [__] army
but even after those things people were
like who are all these comics
that you don't show us so what happened
to comedy central was they kind of lost
credibility
and quibbed instead of [__] looking
at comedy central and going
we don't want to become them and hire
all these [__] bums to [__]
because crippy had just a bunch of
brought up shows i'm not here insulting
anybody or putting anybody down
but they didn't go to any of us they
didn't go to duncan they didn't go to
[__] kim dillon
they didn't go to burke chrysler they
didn't go to nobody
so what the [__] right yeah what the
[__]
whose fault is that because we're bad
boys or whatever the [__] because we're
comics
but you went with that you know how many
actors do you see on tv shows
that the tv shows keep getting canceled
and they keep bringing them back on
another format
i don't know how many [__] shows
they're gonna give these people but at
the same time tim dillon's sitting at
home
andrew schultz is sitting at home makes
you got a [__] wonder like what the
[__] are these people doing that quibby
how can andrew schultz be at home how
wasn't andrew schultz the [__] lead
show on quippy
i'm not even talking about joey diaz
here i'm old i'm out of it
you know whatever i got white hair i do
drug whatever the [__] you want to say
forget me
what about [__] uh annie lederman
where was her quibby [__] show where
was andrew schultz quibby [__] show
where was tim dillon's quibby [__]
show nah why would they go with people
who are doing things
let's pick up the same [__] stiffs
that have been on tv
for 20 years boring you the [__] deck
like
that then you complain about netflix you
know this is what happens
you don't go with the people who are
going to take you to the [__]
promised land
you went with the same people who are
breaking tvs for the last 20 years
20 years they've been breaking tvs
that's who quippy decided to get into
business with
20 years of [__] bad television let's
get back on the boat with these [__]
idiots
and show you bad tv for 10 minutes
that's what i need
10 different tv 10 minute [__] shows
that are bad
for love of [__] people i'm sorry i'm
going off today but it's true
you know i'm a sydney i'm out of the
game i'm out of the game i'm on the
[__] sidelines
i'm on one of these guys la's where the
game is at all this [__] i'm done
i'm just letting you guys know that i
hope you're seeing this i hope you're
paying attention to these things
quirby went out of business there was no
rogan on there
there was no red band on there there was
no tony hinchcliffe on there
there was [__] nobody in there so
what are you doing you're telling people
you want them to start a network
but you don't go with the [__] people
that are doing things it just [__]
drives me crazy but as uncle joey i
don't have to worry about those things
no more
i'm very happy with my [__] little
life now in new jersey
i'm a full-time dad i'm a part-time
entertainer
i'm not surrounded with that [__] no
more it just makes you
[__] sit back and laugh and go what
the [__] didn't you learn your lesson i
was in shock
listen i wasn't putting the maluka on
quibby by no means
i have friends that were on quippy you
know but
jesus [__] christ they're already out
of business that's it
10 minute shows already that's it [__]
anyway back to the situation that had
done
i've been getting a lot of [__]
emails lately a lot of little [__]
tidbits that joey you look better
you look happier whatever
i didn't know what was going on with me
in the last two or three weeks
because i went from a state of [__]
panic
a state of confusion and then
i mean thank god for mike you know we
got the podcast going october 5th
and this is the eighth podcast we've
done and uh
you know things have slowed up for me i
had to slow them down
nobody slowed them down for me i had to
put a [__]
put my foot down and do what i thought
was best
for me and my family i took care of my
family i focused on my family getting
them out of la
getting the house in jersey you know
getting her in school she's in school
four days a week
she's at the after school program she
plays with [__] kids on the street
she's [__] happy my wife is [__]
very happy you know
she's got friends she's got a life
friday night we went out to
uh we went out with friends and on the
way home i go where's your other friend
give her a call and she goes you know i
might as well
and my wife ended up going out for a
drink with her you know the
some outdoor thing just until like 10 or
11 o'clock
i feel very happy for my daughter and my
wife
but i didn't know what i was feeling i
know i i didn't need to climb up in the
daytime no more
i know that i'm not confused anymore but
then i started feeling this other
[__]
thing coming on like the last three
weeks wasn't confusion
it wasn't uh anxious
it wasn't anger it had nothing to do
with that it was just like
something just wasn't right you know
something just wasn't right i was having
a good time with mike
i'm having a good time going down uncle
vinnie's on wednesday nights
you know it's like i tell people it's
the most i could do for right now
i had to do this step by step and you
know just
i can't keep looking at this how
beautiful is this oh my god look at this
can you imagine sticking this up your
ass what type of party you have
you put to use that as a suppository see
how high you are
forget the [__] edibles i did on
friday night i was [__] up friday
night
thank you for watching that tape i was
[__] up because fridays i got [__]
nothing to do
i got nothing to do on friday i'm done
for the week i'm sitting here waiting
for my daughter to come home
usually sometimes i go up north but it
was rainy something was going down
so friday had nothing to do my friend
was coming down anyway
we were going out to dinner so when i
met them
i gave them an edible they were like
where's that other boy you were talking
about so
we're not even talking about 100
milligrams i'm not even eating the abx
no more i still got a ton of abx i'm
saving those for
my my tolerance has gone down so these
pro tabs are just 25 milligrams
the last time i ate at abx i fell asleep
at jimmy florentine's house during
sunday football
so and i still love you guys i still got
a ton of abx i love the [__] product
it's still great
i'm just [__] too old for an abx
right now it'll kill me
so i've been just dealing with these
little pro tabs just to take them
you know and be able to just be social
you know
so i ate like two and like four in the
afternoon
just to get the blood going and then i
[__] met my friends for dinner with
my wife and my daughter
and they asked me before we left what
happened to that thing so when i put
[__] a couple in their hands i popped
two more
now i'm running at 100 milligrams which
is usually nothing for uncle joey
then i come home and i pop two more like
eight i was bored i was upstairs with my
wife i
answered all this stuff we were watching
some [__] movie or something
and then i started doing my sleep age
and that's completely different that's a
complete different territory
because my sleep aids are all like two
milligrams [__]
so let's say i take five pills yeah it's
two milligrams but it still adds up to
ten you know what i'm saying
let's say i put two kicamos under my
[__] tongue the
subliminal it's two [__] things
but it's still four milligrams and then
when i make the tea you know how many
nights
i've fallen asleep with the tea on my
lap
you have no idea getting back to what
joe rogan says
i'm the funniest guy in the world it's
not on stage
it's the [__] that i do all stays
the little remarks i make and the [__]
that happens to me
that i don't remember to tell you guys
you know how many nights
all right so one night i spilled the tea
one night i actually fell asleep with
the [__] teeth
once i drink the tea that's the night
cap right there
so you like last night i didn't take no
medical sliding it was monday
who takes an edible on a monday what
type of animal i used to eat them on
mondays and i live back in l.a
but since i've been here i don't need to
take them on a monday i got too much on
my plate
on mondays tuesdays wednesdays and
thursdays
i got too much on my plate last night i
didn't take any edibles
last night i put [__] maybe
three things under my tongue and i ate
maybe three of the [__] pills
and i drank the tea at like
maybe 10 to 10 i was done with my night
last night
and guys i remember walking upstairs at
10th place last night was one of the
rare nights i didn't fall asleep on the
couch
i mean i usually do for like 10 minutes
and then i catch myself
but usually i fall asleep [__]
watching tv at night like i
and i fall asleep as soon as i finish
that tea
some nights i just sip one thing at a t
and i [__] go to
the other night i woke up in the middle
of night the tea was next to me
i had taken two sips it was freezing now
i'm waking i got up i'm like what the
[__]
is this but the t puts me the [__] out
but sometimes all those edibles add up
and [__] friday night i got [__] up
i've been that [__] up in my couple
weeks jack i made a [__] tape on
youtube
i don't know what the [__] i was talking
about i tried to watch the tape the
other day
i passed out that night and i woke up
and i had to warm up a [__] meal
that's how [__]
that's how [__] hungry i was at about
three o'clock i had a whole chinese
festival going up in my living room
because my wife had gotten chinese food
earlier that day she goes we'll save it
tomorrow
for lunch bob you i thought it wasn't a
lot i tore into
three little wontons in a soup i make
out they had good wonton soup in my
neighborhood good wonton soup
and i had a white rice a little bit of
white rice
and she had szechuan beef so i had a
bunch of the spicy shredded beef
at two in the morning three in the
morning i [__] woke up the next day
was a piece of rice and my sleep apnea
mask
just one single piece of rice i looked
at it i'm like what the [__]
where the [__] is my life going this is
the [__]
you people need to see what i'm gonna
start making a video for you guys
what's an uncle joey's sleep apnea mask
this morning
when i go off on munchies i'm in the
morning i woke up and there was pieces
of [__]
popcorn everywhere i must have been
eating that [__]
my daughter's cheese popcorn or some
[__] i don't even know i have to [__]
like for a while there during the
pandemic in march and april
i was going deep with those abx's
when the [__] pandemic first hit i
gained 16
[__] pounds the first month because
i was getting so [__] high up my
anxiety was so high off the charts
i was eating close to 600 milligrams a
night and i ain't [__] kidding you
when i ain't [__] kidding you you
could get lee on the [__] phone
we were popping those things i know i
was he would laugh at me i don't know
how you do it
i got to do it my insides were on
[__] fire
so i was waking up in the middle every
[__] night i would munch out
and that's why that's the only negative
to the edibles
because i can smoke dope all day and not
eat one [__] day
i've only had oatmeal today i smoked two
joints this morning early
early and i had oatmeal no toast no
nothing
for lunch i have a protein shake maybe
something a little later than for dinner
whatever
so yeah i don't brief it doesn't affect
my [__] appetite
edibles make me go [__] bananas
i mean to the point where it's not good
it's scary
like the cheese is gone the ham is gone
chips are gone you know i don't drink
soda
thank god i don't eat cake or cookies
nothing like that i just eat [__]
food
dang [__] god man but last night was
a very weird night
because i went to bed early
you know like 10 30 quarter to 11 i had
to be when i went to [__] bed
and i woke up like a 4 30.
i didn't have to pee or anything i just
woke up
i laid there for about seven eight
minutes
and i was like man maybe i'll just get
up
go downstairs right a little bit maybe
take uh
two more droplets of the
cbd maybe two more droplets of the uh
the kikimo tincture and i'll go back to
bed but i go [__] i gotta do a podcast
early
i gotta get up i don't wanna be [__]
sleepy for mike or [__] up for mike
you know i want to
be as good as i could be on these things
so i said [__] it i'll just uh try to
fall back to sleep on my own
and i got comfortable whatever i laid
down and
it wasn't happening and my mind started
thinking about stuff you know like
that's the natural
i didn't want to get up and something
hit me
something hit me that hadn't hit me in a
long time
that feeling i had that little feeling
i've been having the last maybe two
weeks because i
i tell you that this goes on in like two
week increments you know like
for the last eight weeks i felt
different the last two weeks you know
so when from august 19th to september
1st
i moved into my house i had a weird
feeling and then from september 1st to
maybe the 15th
it took me that long to get rid of that
full-time anxiety
and then from the 15th of september to
october 1st
maybe the fear decimated a little bit i
got to fear out
you know i started accepting that you
know the church wasn't happening i
started missing lee
i started accepting a lot of things by
beginning of october
and then you know thank god for mike he
called me because i'm ready to go and we
started doing this
and i progressed fantastically this
month
but something else happened uh the last
two weeks you know
i mean listen my buddy died my
sister-in-law died
uh my wife is walking with a [__] uh
thing on her foot
she broke during the [__] pandemic my
wife was playing
whatever the [__] not tennis but the
other [__] with mercy
and she stepped wrong and she thought
there was something wrong with her foot
and she just came back yesterday with
the doctor with a [__] thing on her
foot
she's limping around she's gotta wear it
for like a month so
yeah listen it's life bad things are
gonna happen
and you're gonna react to them you know
i miss my my buddy
i miss my sister-in-law you know i see
what my brother's going through
i see what a lot of people are going
through i mean i'm going to tell you
something guys that
i'm going to be strictly honest with you
i'm going to tell you how hard it is on
people right now
financially this is the first time in my
life
and i'm not talking about it being hard
on me i'm talking about me trying you
know
helping people and whatever this is the
first time in my life
if you want i'll show mike just to prove
it to you that i got 100
on my paypal this is the first time
in since i've had paypal that i've had
like 52
in there because people are going
through a hard time
i usually have you know 600 500 400
people buy cds you know whatever [__]
like that
this is the first time i got under 100
bucks because people are [__] hurting
people need money people don't know what
they know people are moving in
i mean maybe you're not going through it
or whatever but you have to be
you know drive up and down your streets
you know businesses are going out
people aren't working the full amounts
you know and and the holidays are going
to be rough on some people this is rough
you know we're not playing [__] games
here you know people needed help and
whatnot
but this morning when i was laying there
in bed i didn't want to get up
i didn't have to pee but i thought about
what this latest feeling was that i had
that was in me and the feeling was
happiness
the last two weeks i ever since mercy's
been going to school for
days listen i was happy when she was
going to school two days a week
because we were still covering the
spread around the house there's still
tons of stuff to do our neighbors are
great people
our neighbors around the corner are
great people the florentines are a great
family
i still had a great support system but
uh this morning i finally came to the
conclusion like
i remember even smiling in bed like i
just smiling going
i can't remember the last time i was
this complete
like this complete regardless of what's
going on outside
people have my empathy and i sympathize
with everybody
but for me my insides i haven't been
this happy
i don't remember within a long [__]
time maybe since i got into the comedy
store but even then
i was dealing with the pain of my
daughter i mean right now i am
this is the best joey diaz i've ever
been and i didn't even know it
i didn't even know what happiness felt
like like
total total happiness like
you know and then watching the
documentary my friends are happy with
the [__] mukberg and [__]
my door everybody's happy around me you
know i mean people struggling people are
dying
you know this is live people getting
flat tires you know
uh you know my wife whatever with the
[__] foot now i gotta hear like
she's dragging the other foot but
besides all that stuff i could really
look you guys in the eye
and tell you i'm happy as [__] lee's up
in milwaukee he's taken care of he's
going home on friday
i'm happy he's finally going home to his
mom
uh you know he's gonna be home for all
the holidays
the jewish high days you know all that
stuff
so i'm happy for him he's taken care of
you know nothing bad is going on with
him
steve simone's doing his thing i miss
him you know being del rey
i miss my brother i miss that
[__] with all my heart
i please support dean delray he had
[__]
rob haufferd on and he when i talked to
him after he taped daisy dc
it was like talking to a five-year-old
kid that just robbed the candy store
like he was so [__] happy so if you
get a chance support [__] dean del
rey
you know hit him up tell him dean we're
proud of you because
he really is doing a good job that's one
guy that
never brought me down he really
understood l.a
he wasn't desperate he wasn't needy
he didn't have it all the different
marks that people at that level
of stand-up have i don't know if it was
his age i don't know if he was because
he was that wise of a dude
but dean delray i miss you to death he
gets
all the love from my heart i mean he
kept plugging
what did i tell you this was about guys
there's going to be a pandemic
and you're gonna have to wear a mask and
you're gonna have to do this and you
have to do that
but if you lay down then life's gonna
take you down
but if you keep going head on listen i
had to take that little period off
just to acclimate just to see what the
[__] was going to happen here
and i tell you something even though i
wasn't moving forward
now i could tell you i was moving
forward because i was taking care of my
mental health somebody even suggested
that to me the other that
they were like we could see your mental
health is a lot better guys
i was surrounded by desperation
[__] you know when you're in that
business you're desperate and i'm not
mad at you
i'm sure i was desperate the first year
i was there also
but when you see people in these
desperate positions
what really shocked me what what i've
stepped away from
was desperation and greed i stepped away
from all that
the desperation and greed i saw the last
six or seven years in l.a
was [__] disgusting and it went
it manifested up on top and it ran down
so the agents were greedy the [__]
the [__] client this was greedy and
they all got one that lost their [__]
minds
and i tell you you know
happiness you can't buy happiness what i
have in my stomach right now beside
fat and a [__] up liver and a kidney
and god knows what else
you know pubic hairs are settling down
there who the [__] knows but what else i
have in my stomach
is i can look you guys straight in the
face and tell you i haven't been this
happy a long time
i didn't even know how happiness
manifested itself
i didn't even know i had no idea because
i haven't felt it in so long
for years i nothing was right
for years i felt like i could never
reach this point where nothing was
right this isn't about money or tv shows
or back end or that this is just about
life right now me being in this house
me just living like i'm not doing much
i'm doing stand up once a week and
that's all you're probably gonna get out
of me for a while
i'm not i'm not looking to do a lot of
[__] things right now
i'm looking to get healthy i've been
writing some stand-up
i have been writing them in the book i'm
trying
you know so that tells me also of my
[__] progress
because i couldn't write any [__]
jokes man
i'm writing jokes again they're not
[__] bill bird type [__] jokes or
dave chappelle type jokes but i'm
writing and little steps
become big steps the more i keep [__]
doing it
but happiness is something that i
haven't [__]
you know you get temporary happiness
somebody licks your balls
[__] you get a tv show you know
you [__] have a great weekend at a
comedy club
you know somebody tells you you had a
funny joke those are just like temporary
moments of happiness
in what's going on in your reality but
to look you straight in the face and
tell you that i'm happy
all the way down to my balls i'm happy
with the decision i made
i'm happy that i stuck to my plan i'm
happy that i stuck to my word
i'm happy that the people around me
didn't get [__] you know
listen this could have been a lot worse
off i lost two people i could have lost
how many people have died from this
[__] culvert thing
a lot i could have lost a lot of friends
i lost two
and both deaths were not the covet one
was
and the other one was just a heart
attack so
you know this could have all been
different but for the first time in a
long time
i'm [__] happy and you people witness
it you people could see it on my face
you could hear it in my voice and you
could feel it in my heart i don't have
those things around me that are making
me unhappy
and i can't describe the feeling to you
i can't even [__] tell you
and i didn't even know we don't even
know what true happiness is
you know little things don't bother me
no more the things that used to bother
me
don't bother me anymore i have a
tremendous relationship and my daughter
listen
yeah i [__] up i lost a daughter
before
i ruined the wedding who hasn't who
hasn't ruined the marriage with their
behavior on drugs or whatever
if you haven't [__] ruined the
marriage then good for you
you know bon jovi got it right the first
time a lot of us have to get married
after yeah he's the only guy that got it
right the first time
he's been married since [__] slippery
with wet or whatever
but i'm talking about us as he you know
i haven't [__] been happy you know i
mean all of us [__] make mistakes
i got the right wife i'm having a
just a great time with my daughter guys
you know the bus picks her up at 8 30.
we all like i get up at like seven you
know we all do our own little things in
the morning
but then we all huddle up before she
goes to school and we talk and she tells
me about a day
and what her plans are gonna be and who
she's gonna see
today she was talking to me and she goes
oh hold on one second
and she ran and she came back and put a
little dodger hat on
she's getting ready for the dodgers
tonight and [__] so
you know things are good man it's not
about [__] being in movies
it's not about being on the [__] road
it's not about driving a mercedes benz
if you're not generally happy
this [__] ain't gonna work listen for
the most part
in l.a i was about 60 percent there
you know i i had to do [__] to get me
there
but i was about 60 percent there here
i got to tell you guys i'm 100 happy in
all
aspects my relationships my friends
what's going on with mike
you know just all this [__] the road
it'll be there forever i'm not worried
about the road
philly i'm gonna miss you i missed you
last week
but i'll be down there next year and
we'll put it together at the parks
casino
and all the places where we schedule
whatever the [__] i don't i don't want
to put anybody in danger
i don't want to make anybody feel like
how i feel when i go to a [__]
restaurant even if i'm sitting outside
and somebody coughs
the hair on my neck's pop-up and they
should you know whatever
i can't imagine being inside a theater
or being inside a comedy club
i do uh vinnie's on wednesday but it's
what
38 [__] people nobody's gonna get
hurt you know they got the doors open
we got some ventilation in there dino
vinnie is doing everything
he can to make it safe in there and i
wouldn't go down there if he was
if i went down and there was a hundred
people i wouldn't [__] go up i just
wouldn't go up
you know bert was the one that told me
he don't like doing inside stuff
because he did an inside gig and the guy
packed it up
so no i'm not backing up inside we'll do
low numbers
i don't want to [__] do comedy
outside when i might have [__] magic
act it's 38 degrees it's friday night
comedy outside is over with
you know the heater is temporarily the
heater is great until that wind comes
off the [__] hudson
and knocks you off your [__] chair in
november or december
so my comedy is done for november and
this time i'm just doing
if you don't see me at uncle vinnie's
i'm not going anywhere and every
wednesday i'm gonna do uncle buddies
december
it's not in the cards yet we don't know
what's gonna happen in december
but i'm doing tonight and then i'm
taking the first two weeks of november
off
and then i'm going back on wednesday
nights i hope that he has december open
if things open up
i'm gonna have to finish a movie who
knows what the [__] i'm gonna have to do
but that's all i want to tell you
[__] today that
for the first time it wasn't cocaine for
the first time it wasn't robbing
somebody
for the first time it wasn't doing a
show or opening for anybody or a
particular movie
you know it's like i told you last week
that in l.a
it's programmed for disneyland to
entertain your kids
here you know we're programmed for the
kids to entertain each other
for years i've been using
[Music]
not but doing things
that i thought would make me happy to be
genuinely happy inside is a [__] gift
that
only happens a couple times in your
[__] life
i mean i don't remember being this happy
at my wedding i don't remember being
this happy when i graduated eighth grade
i don't remember being this happy
because i got laid i don't remember
being this happy at all
this has just been a genuine happiness
and i want to thank you guys i want to
i'm going to tell you who helped me a
lot in this
what process helped me a lot because
remember the podcast ended on the 15th
patreon i love you [__] with
all my heart
thank you you asked the right questions
i answered the right [__]
answers you know i looked at a video of
patreon and me in august
i was looking rough i was beat up
i was [__] scared i was confused
you know i was a lot of [__] things
today
oh i shed all that [__] i still got my
[__] rash
you know you can't get rid of the rash i
still got that ball rash i still got the
[__] uh fungi toenail
you know i got nails now can you [__]
believe this look at this [__]
i haven't bit my [__] nails how is
that
even possible my daughter stopped using
ketchup
and i stopped biting my [__] nails
can you believe this i stopped biting my
nails
what the [__] possesses a person that's
been biting this nail
for 50 [__] years to stop biting his
[__] nails
this has just been a tremendous [__]
thing for me
so i thank you and i want you to know
that i made the right move
and i want you to know that i i felt the
support you gave me
when i was moving and the kind emails
and the kind messages
and for watching my videos i'm all so
[__] proud of you [__] i
said joey
go the [__] away you're too old you're
this you're that
i just want honesty out of you people i
keep i keep looking at this thing going
jesus christ this looks like a living
tiramisu
look at this only tiramisu could bring
you this much [__] happiness
i don't even know what type of weed this
is this is i don't even know i don't
want to say
because i might be the wrong weed but oh
i can't wait to laugh that podcast you
know what i'm saying and that's it and
that's that
you know we have to we we go through all
these [__] feelings
and when we get the right ones we don't
even recognize
that they're there like when we get the
right feelings we don't really i
i don't even know what that feeling is i
must be having anxiety no
and that's why a couple weeks ago i just
[__] with the anxiety medication
[__] all this [__] i'm gonna bring
myself to life on my own
i can't keep depending on this anxiety
medication my sister was like when you
feel it in the afternoon
just take a half and no [__] that [__]
see i got caught up in that [__]
that [__] people been dealing with
anxiety since the beginning of [__]
life
breathing through their [__] nose
riding your bike lifting weights
i'm gonna do it the same way and look
this is the [__] result
i'm so ugly [__] i'm still
getting older
but you know what man there's nothing
like [__] bringing up your own energy
haven't gone acupuncture in a while i
haven't even found an acupuncturist here
in l.a
and uh new jersey my friend says he's
got a chinese one for me
i'm ready to go speaking of chinese
people i want to give a shout out to a
chinese dude
who works at the male he's a mailman
with my little brother guy tabasco in c
caucus new jersey
guy tabasco always tells about this
little mailman he works for a chinese
dude
that's a fan of the podcast and while i
remember here i just want to let you
know i love guy with all my heart
but i want to give a shout out to the
chinese mailman because he's always
telling guys
[__] about what i say on the podcast
and whatnot i'm sure i'll get a call
from guy tonight saying what the [__]
diaz
you got me in trouble with the chinese
mailman nah he said you were your buddy
they listened to the show so i might as
well give them a [__] shout out who
gives a [__] here
it's wednesday [__] it's
september 28th
we're coming up on halloween guess what
else i'm doing
i'm going to a halloween [__] party
i'm dressing up
i don't know you got to dress up by the
[__] first initial of your name
so that means joker i'm gonna go as a
jerk off
i think i'm gonna paint myself as a dick
with like [__] sperm on my neck i
don't [__] know
what else begins with jay jerk off joker
jamock maybe i could just be a [__]
jamok i don't [__] know
maybe i'll just go as jose that's what i
think i was gonna go but
put like a little mustache in and get
like a little hat with some
[__] maracas and [__]
and walk in there and just talk spanish
to people i was thinking about that you
know
listen it's halloween when was the last
time i dressed up follow the [__]
weed
hold on joe you want a halloween mess
put cellophane on your face
you will see the sand for the sun when
uh that's comes home with the cellophane
she goes honest i even got something for
you and they gave a little ball of saran
wrap
she opened it up she's like fred what's
this he goes that's your halloween mask
put it on
we still got it it's wednesday
the 28th halloween's coming
that's it and that's that i just want to
check in with you [__] on a
wednesday morning
let you know i'm doing fine let you know
it [__] worked
and let you know i'm grateful for you
[__] for giving me a chance
and for sticking it out with me today we
broke the third wall we introduced mike
we know mike's laughing on here and [__]
and little by little
we're gonna start zooming guesting and
uh we're gonna get this up and running
how you want it
i'm [__] glad i didn't start
in that bar because we found out
something about the body at night the
other night we had company
and we came downstairs and we were just
talking [__]
and i had my computer on you know what
well the computer sits downstairs
the tv was on and my wife put the heater
on
and the power went out how about that
that's the first siren you've heard in
eight episodes remember in l.a
you heard [__] sirens every [__]
day that's the first siren
that we've heard in the [__] month
here i haven't heard a helicopter i'm
getting ptsd
from not hearing [__] helicopters in
l.a that's how good it's been here
but uh i don't even know what the [__] i
was saying it's time to smoke this week
this [__] reefer has broken my
[__]
uh focus today thank god i took [__]
alpha brain this morning i gotta thank
them too because
i gotta be honest with you guys let me
tell you what my logic was
my head and my heart was so [__] up
before i left la
i thought that doing the alpha brain
would [__] work against me
and make me get all [__] up so thank
god i stayed off the alpha brain
until i moved into the house like i gave
it 10 days
so i started my cycle alpha brain like
september 10th around there
i think it was a monday and here we are
today not even a month later
and i'm thinking clearer i'm sharper
you know saying this ain't no [__]
make-believe [__]
my new mood at night that helps me lay
down relaxed a little bit more
you see him i'm you know you can tell
i'm a little more more relaxed
i'm not agitated i'm not giving honest
on it a [__] push here i'm just
telling you the things i did
to get to where i am today it was just a
couple things but i knew getting out of
l.a was one of them
maybe right now you're feeling a little
weird about your situation and stuff
and you don't see things happen i would
have left l.a
five years ago but i knew the hall
across the country
was i didn't want to think about doing
it but once i did it
and once we got out of the way the cats
are fine
my family's fine i'm fine
some stuff got broken some stuff got
lost
who gives a [__] everybody's happiness
is back
and that was the main purpose of this
[__] trip
we just weren't happy no more you have
to accept it sometimes man that
sometimes you're just not happy
whether it's in a marriage it could be a
[__] job that you have
it could be something that you do it
doesn't make you happy you know
if it doesn't make you happy don't keep
doing it don't add little substitutes
you know i thought by adding a tv show
whatever was going to make me happy no
what was going to make me happy was me
getting out of there and starting from
scratch again
yeah i miss my friends i miss what i was
doing but it was time for a new [__]
life
and i'm happy you guys got to witness me
doing it
from a to z and didn't have to hear
about it you're witnessing it
you're seeing it you're seeing all the
videos you look at it
i'm a different [__] person i mean we
change every seven years anyway
but as far as our insights our inside
state of [__] saying
unless we lessen or add more aggravation
or whatever
i'm not even getting agitated at the
[__] i used to no more
doesn't matter to me no more these
things i have no beefs with nobody i
have no
regrets with nobody i'm just trying to
live my life
being a better dad of being a better
person and still trying to be funny you
know what i'm saying we're going to be
funny
we'll have my day again in the [__]
sun but it won't be till this [__]
shit's over with
and then we'll go out there and do it
[__] right but in the meantime
you guys got me here twice a week you
got patreon
we [__] around on twitter we do whatever
we can you know from time to time we'll
release the [__] video to you
[__]
i'm here for you guys but most
importantly i'm happy that you've been
here for me
because like i couldn't have made this
[__] run without you guys
half the [__] i do is to back up my
[__] talk on these podcasts
after should i do you know i haven't
gone to white castle yet i know
i know i deserve a smack in the face
from you people
i know i should deserve i haven't gone
to white castle yet
i've been to [__] carvel twice you
know i was telling my wife
i can't believe i haven't eaten
entertainments yet i know
that i could just move here and die i
could i could die i could last one month
in jersey
all i gotta do is open the valve i got
lovates close to me
i got shot right close to me i got
everybody close to me and they got all
the good [__]
they got chicken cutlets they got
everything i need to get [__] huge
i've been [__] towing the line for my
health
and so you guys could see it i'm not
[__] bullshitting you guys
i work hard i work hard at all [__]
ends you know i could just sit upstairs
all day
i'm dying for one of those hostess apple
pies
jesus christ i used to eat eight of
those a day and nothing would happen
if i eat apple pie right now my central
nervous system
would just sizzle and the fat would just
spread from everywhere
i can't i won't even drink a [__]
coke i mean nothing
nothing i've been drinking water if i do
drink iced tea it's snapple [__] iced
tea
the [__] one everybody go get a slice
because listen
i don't care what diet you're on you
still gotta eat a piece of pizza every
day
there's a cheese slice around my that's
one thing about new jersey baby
i got my slice back l.a didn't
understand the mentality of the slice
la you walk into a plate let me get a
slice they put on a piece of paper
they got to give it to the mexican the
mexican gives it back to you then they
call your name
that's not a slice here is where you get
a [__] slice
you walk in let me get that one right
there
the guy throws it at you you give the
two dollars
you get your snap when you're good to go
let me tell you something a piece of
[__] pizza here in jersey is like a
vitamin
it's like taking a vitamin if you don't
eat your pizza in jersey
you didn't take your [__] vitamins
today and i haven't gone overboard i
haven't had no shrimp parmesan
no chicken parmesan just a slice
remember a slice is like going to a
[__] therapist
just one slice i grew up on a slice
every day all saying you put me out
there with these [__]
uh granola eaters and they don't know
how to sell a slice of [__] pizza
here i just go around the corner walk in
how you doing what's going on vote for
me
give me a slice [__] the other day i
went to vintage records whatever
vinyl vintage over in my wood bridge
that's part of the [__] journey you
got a place next door some little
mexicans
i think i want italian hidden in the
back tied up he just gave him the recipe
he just goes in and takes the name
the mexicans are spitting out [__] uh
slices that were [__] tremendous so
if you ever go
to vintage vinyl and woodbridge like
three doors down they got a pizza parlor
nice not the best i'm not so bro i can't
find that [__] slice of pizza
it's just a slice of pizza it's very
nice
very cheesy the tomato sauce got some
wang to it
and it's tremendous whether you like it
or not we all got different tastes
but if you're not in new jersey anyway
you can suck my dick we're eating some
[__] real pizza here
that's it and that's that uncle joey's
diaz's joint
is [__] done with i'm happy you guys
watched today
i'm happy you guys made it till
wednesday and i'll see you [__]
tonight at uncle vinnie's
again thank you for everything you've
done for me uh
and i'll keep doing my thing here too
but this just goes to show you man
you could have 20 girlfriends you can
have the
18 porsches you can have money in the
bank and not be happy
it's the simple things that sometimes
make you happy
that we overlook don't overlook the
simple things in your life
little things just squeezing my daughter
telling my wife i love her you know
going to get a piece of cheese pizza
with jimmy florentine and his son
you know it's the little things that i
missed when i was living out there
and i put these back into my life and
here we are today
a lot happier a lot better and guess
what
if i'm happy i'm gonna be [__] funny
so pay attention you know i'm gonna be
doing some podcasts in the next couple
weeks
i'm gonna be doing history hyenas with
my boys
i'm gonna be doing [__] uh
ryan sicklers again i got a couple
podcasts
on tap so i'll be around [__]
i love you thank you very much for
watching
and thank you very much for being a part
of uncle joey's joint all right thank
god we didn't move out to the bar
with all that drama we're right here we
got some nice lighting
we got bruce we got sid the squid we got
my man joe rogan
we got charlie b and we got ac dc
covering the [__] nut
and that's it and that's that i love you
guys have a great week
and now for a message from our sponsors
that was a blast today thank you for
watching
uncle joey's joint but before we [__]
end this i gotta talk to you about
something listen
stamps.com brings the post office into
the comfort of your home
this is why i love this company the
holiday season is coming after saturday
that's it guys it's thanksgiving and
you'll be sending [__]
and this year they're going to be double
as busy we've been on that [__] we've
been ordering stuff
all year the post office isn't just
going to be busy this year
it's going to set new records between
the covert and the whole thing and
people sending stuff
but you don't need the hassle with
stamps.com you can mail anything
from the convenience of your own home
plus it saves you money with deep
discounts you can't get out the post
office
stamps.com brings the post office into
the comfort of your home
skip the line print postage 24 7.
any letter any size package going
anywhere
in the world right from your [__]
couch are you kidding me or what
and the best part is the mailman comes
and picks it up
no contact required it's that simple you
also get
great discounts you get five cents off
every
first class stamp did you hear me five
cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40 off
priority mail you can't beat that
plus you save up to 62 percent on ups
rates guys stamps.com is a no-brainer
especially now saving you time money
and keeping you healthy and safe don't
spend a minute
of your holiday season at the post
offices here
sign up for stamps.com instead there's
no risk
use my code joey j-o-e-y and you get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments
or contracts it's easy go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
home page and press joey
that stamps.com preston joey
never go to the post office again the
joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion like i told you the beginning
i'm an old man
i live on this stuff when i go to the
gym i put tapes on at night before i go
to sleep
i pop two gummies after the shower
i rub the cream lotion on my knees
and on my calves as a moisturizer i put
it on my face
the tincture to go to sleep at night
they have high levels
of cbd cbd lion has it all for you
you can't come at me with a [__]
story when it comes to cbd lion
because their pride and performance go
to cbdlion.com right now
read read learn about cbd
cbn how it works with your body your
body type
cbd lion has all this information for
you this is not
some [__] high school [__] drop
out on the corner at the liquor store
this is [__] science go to
cbdlion.com right now
go to the webpage try the gummies the
tropical ones
the raspberry ones try a backball you
will not be sorry
press in code joey and get 20
off delivered right to your [__]
house okay you can't [__] lose
cbd lion the wind is coming bones are
going to be cracking
you're going to need this more than ever
go to cbdline.com right now
preston joey and get 10 percent off your
order i don't even know what it is we're
just switching as we go along
i want to thank cbdlion.com one more
time
and i want to thanks that stamps dot com
plus i want to thank you guys
for [__] being here and watching the
show on mondays and wednesdays have a
great weekend
we'll see you next week
who's better than you
[Music]